viviana medina la asociación de
trabajadores y trabajadoras de agencias
de empleo llevó a cabo una conferencia
de prensa para volver a elevar el
reclamo de asistencia a estas
trabajadoras y trabajadores en general
puede comentarnos de qué se trata
específicamente
bueno la conferencia de prensa que se
tuvo alrededor de tres demandas
específicas
es el acceso a la salud y el acceso
completo a la salud a los cuidados
médicos al acceso a los fondos
financieros
y por supuesto estamos pidiendo la
emisión del certificado de selección de
quebec en base a esas tres
reivindicaciones se llevó a cabo la
conferencia de prensa con el testimonio
de cuatro mujeres que han estado
trabajando desde hace mucho tiempo antes
de la pandemia durante la pandemia ahora
la segunda ola en condiciones muy
precarias y pues arriesgando su vida y
pues
parece ser que ni el gobierno ni la
sociedad quiere ver a estas trabajadoras
a estos trabajadores y trabajadores pues
pues para aclarar un poco la situación
cuando hablamos de estas trabajadoras y
trabajadores estamos hablando de gente
que no tiene un estatus definido estamos
hablando de gente que no tiene un
estatus legal en este momento en el país
y debido a que como puede ser entonces
que se encuentren trabajando países pero
no tengan ese estatus de a diferentes
razones no puede ser puede ser
demandantes de asilo que perdieron el
proceso no de refugio y bueno quedaron
que muchas veces también esos procesos
son la piel hecha de que hayan perdido
son la consecuencia de los malos
asesoramientos 9 que los abogados o los
consejeros
las personas y ahí se va viniendo se va
desarrollando toda una bola de nieve
incontrolable
muchas veces también puede ser como el
testimonio de chery de hoy de una
trabajadora que doméstica filipina que
vino bajo el programa entonces pueden
ser por diferentes razones pero pero
digamos el hecho de que hayan
caído en esta en esta ilegalidad entre
comillas pues tiene que ver mucho
también con la con las políticas
totalmente racistas de inmigración y eso
es lo que también estamos denunciando
evidentemente cuando hablas de políticas
racistas específicamente a qué te
refieres pues sí digamos que los
programas muchas veces están hechos para
que para que las mujeres no puedan o las
personas no puedan defenderse no puedan
apelar a las decisiones de inmigración
no te puedo hablar del programa de
trabajadores agrícolas pero
específicamente digamos estas mujeres
que estuvieron dando testimonio el día
de hoy pues han sido víctimas de eso no
que han caído en procesos donde
se les ha juzgado duramente sin que
hayan tenido oportunidad a hacer
realmente escuchadas y volver a tomar la
oportunidad volver a tener la
oportunidad de replantear el caso que
muchas veces como lo como te digo ellas
llegan acá son mal asesoradas no hablan
el idioma en ese momento no saben caen
en la manipulación de
de géneros que son estafadores porque
esos son es lo que es
y bueno y ahí se sigue todo esto para
partir del momento en que estas personas
llegan al país sea con un permiso
provisorio de trabajo o en la condición
en la que fuere se supone que hay una
habilitación para que se encuentren aquí
y cuando más tarde entran al mercado
laboral en la condición que sea se
supone también que están reconocidas
como personas que están habilitadas a
trabajar como puede ser que habiendo
superado esas dos instancias por más que
se trate de situaciones sin una
definición final de cada uno de los
casos estas personas luego queden a la
deriva no haya ninguna autoridad que se
haga cargo porque en todo caso y esa es
la pregunta en definitiva porque el
gobierno más allá de todos estos
reclamos que se vienen repitiendo desde
hace tiempo insiste en no darles una
cobertura médica
pues porque les conviene no porque
evidentemente no lo quieren hacerse
cargo de la responsabilidad que les toca
el gobierno sabe perfectamente que esta
gente está contribuyendo estas personas
estas mujeres que están trabajando están
contribuyendo a la economía están
haciendo todo lo que debe de hacer y
evidentemente no quieren tomar la
responsabilidad no evidentemente ahora
con todo este contexto del cuvillo pues
lo único que ha venido a destacar son
las igualdades que ya teníamos
evidentemente nosotros tuve veíamos y
seguimos viendo muchas noticias o muchos
reportajes que sea que hablando del
impacto de kobe en estos trabajadores en
muchos sectores pero poco se habla de lo
del impacto que se tiene en las mujeres
específicamente sin estatus no que se
vive también de otra manera y hay toda
esta parte de género entonces
el gobierno no quiere no es simple y
sencillamente no quiere no quiere tomar
responsabilidad una responsabilidad que
está ahí decir que es una cuestión de
voluntad eso se arregla con un poco de
voluntad es decir estar acá están se
llevan muchos años trabajando y siendo
parte de esta sociedad entonces es bueno
listo este cargo no regularizadas
hablando de gente que hace mucho tiempo
que está aquí en la conferencia se
abordó el caso de lourdes castro
un caso que terminó trágicamente puedes
comentar nos del mismo
sí pues ese es un ejemplo tal cual de lo
que se está reivindicando hoy
es una mujer que llegó hace muchos años
en el 2008 no un poco antes
sí bien recuerdo y ella perdió el
estatus en 2008 quiere decir que desde
hace ya casi 11 años que la mujer estaba
en pésimas condiciones de vida y de
trabajo
cuando yo la conocí cuando llego al
centro de trabajadores inmigrantes y ya
llegó por un problema que estaba
sufriendo que estaba viviendo en el
trabajo por abuso psicológico abuso
sexual
y estaba ganando en aquella época cinco
dólares la hora cinco dólares cincuenta
no lo recuerdo exactamente muy prueba
exacto y el empleador sabía el estatus
de ella entonces eso le permitía tener
poder sobre ella y la obligaba a
trabajar jornadas de 13 hasta 16 horas
por día entonces pues fueron muchos años
muchos años de estar en estrés de
desarrollar enfermedades por el trabajo
repetitivo y en el 2000
el año pasado al principio del 2019 ella
tuvo dos accidentes de trabajo muy
graves se cayó de la escalera en una
ocasión y en otra ocasión también tuvo
una caída muy grave
y de ahí ella empezó a estar muy mal su
salud se me vino para abajo para abajo
para abajo para abajo y este año yo
estuve con ella en todos los hospitales
desde el mes de septiembre prácticamente
hasta que murió
pues ella no salió de los hospitales
sufrió dos cirugías tuvo dos cirugías en
menos de 15 días no nunca encontraron
exactamente que era primero le
diagnosticaron una cosa después otra
después otra lo que importa pero la
cuestión lo que se refleja ahí es la
falta de acceso a los cuidados de salud
de tantos años de tantos años
y ahí está el resultado razón por la
cual después después de que las
compañeras de nuestro comité se
enteraron de este fallo fallecimiento
lo primero que hicimos fue tener una
junta donde todas las chicas que
pertenecen a ser parte de este comité
lloraban lloraban sin parar porque
decían este es el espejo de nosotras
esto es lo que nos va a pasar y vamos a
morir vamos a morir porque todas estamos
muy lastimadas hemos desarrollado ya
enfermedades complicadas estamos con
dolores intensos en los cuerpos que no
se arreglan con una pomada evidente
que requieren ya de exámenes más
profundos y no tienen acceso a eso no
porque el costo es muy elevado y para
terminar con el tema de lourdes yo hasta
el día de hoy sigo recibiendo facturas
que ascienden a más de 300 mil dólares
por lo por por lo que ella por el tiempo
que ella estuvo internada y después el
tratamiento que ella necesitaba para
poder más o menos seguir ascendía a los
1.400 dólares es una locura una persona
sin estatus como entonces como a pagar
eso entonces la salud es una cuestión
también de la gente que tiene un papel
entonces hay tras cuenta no y todo esto
es consecuencia de muchos años de vida
precaria pues tantos es precario todo es
precario finalmente lo que castró
retorno a su méxico natal y falleció así
si no equivoco si yo misma la fia
llevará en el aeropuerto y fue muy
fuerte el día que yo la llevé al
aeropuerto porque el aeropuerto estaba
cerrado ella voló en un avión que no
tenía staff era un avión que venía
solamente con trabajadores agrícolas que
regresaba prácticamente vacío y ella iba
en silla de ruedas ella no era capaz ni
siquiera de levantarse cuando cuando
llegamos ahí para registrarse no no era
capaz de pedir a dos personas que iban
en ese vuelo que la cuidara quiere decir
ella no estaba consciente ya
de su estado iba muy mal iba muy muy mal
y efectivamente regreso a morir y porque
se fue también porque adquiere
era imposible ella pudiera obtener los
cuidados que ella requería por lo que te
estoy diciendo el tratamiento costaba
1400 dólares así que regresó a méxico
obligada y regresó a morir porque ella
también estuvo integrada internada y
hasta que falleció vive no tienen
estudios números de cuál es la cantidad
de gente que se encuentra en situación
precaria como la que tú estás
describiendo pues no hay una cifra
actualizada lamentablemente no sabemos
por qué no hay una cifra actualizada
llevar llevan muchos años diciendo que
aquí hay
50.000 personas en estatus sin estatus
eso eso eso ya no puede ser porque hace
muchos años que seguimos repitiendo esas
cifras no tenemos una cifra actual este
no la hay pero si sabemos que son muchos
y muchas las que están padeciendo esto
no a nuestro centro llegan muchos y
muchos con estos problemas y pues cada
vez son más no cada vez son más
las mujeres que se encuentran en esta
situación específicamente yo trabajo con
el comité de mujeres de las asociaciones
de las trabajadoras y trabajadores de
empleo específicamente con mujeres sin
estatus y mi otro y otro y otro voley
como
trabajadores agrícolas provenientes de
latinoamérica entonces yo lo veo lo veo
en un sector o sea lo veo en mi trabajo
todos los días y también a eso se sumen
también trabajadoras temporales
trabajadoras agrícolas que por muchas
razones pierden el estatus y que son
cuestiones administrativas también son
cuestiones de mucho abuso mucho abuso de
estas trabajadoras que pueden venir en
programas
y temporales y que sufren agresiones
sexuales que sufren muchísima
explotación y que terminan escapándose
de esa explotación y caen en esa
ilegalidad entre comillas no y después
es muy difícil poder restablecer el
estatus con la inmigración porque como
te digo inmigración es así es cuadrado
no acepta y el problema más grave
también cuando hablamos también de
trabajadoras extranjeras temporales es
que siempre se juzga cuando hay
cuestiones criminales siempre se juzga
por con la ley de inmigración y entonces
cualquier acusación a nivel criminal
contra los empleadores cae cae al agua
se va al baño pero no procede no avanza
eso hemos tenido muchísimos casos con
eso ya y la gente pierde el estatus ahí
la gente pierde el estatus porque queda
atrapado en ese limbo no
entonces es eso por eso las compañeras
el día de hoy levantaron la voz porque
su es suficiente dijeron no vamos a
seguir muriendo
para pruebas y basta un botón este año
tuvimos 2
y es suficiente dijeron basta cuantas
más cuántas muertes más se necesitan
para que el gobierno nos ofrezca
atención y entonces para terminar cuál
es el reclamo específico que ustedes
están levantando en este momento
queremos que el gobierno nos emita la
carta malady para poder acceder a los
cuidados médicos completos no nada más
por el tema del cob y porque no nada más
el kobe del problema hay muchos
problemas además del cob y de en
cuestiones de salud queremos el acceso a
los fondos financieros también no del
problema del programa federal y también
queremos la emisión del certificado de
selección que ve para que se pueda
comenzar una regularización a nivel
federal
viviana medina muchas gracias por esta
entrevista concluyó que nada
internacional
muchas gracias a ti